We have a new programming language. The language is called Swift, and it totally rules. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 183, recorded on April 29th, 2024. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we interview Doug Greger. This is part four of a five-part interview, in today's interview we chat about the Swift programming language. I spent I don't know if it was a significant amount of time but on two different occasions one was when I was preparing for that talk and then another time I think I looked at it while I was covering a meetup and I I remember actually in that talk, I kind of ranked the languages that I looked at, Rust, Swift, C++, D and Haskell. And I think there was like three or
我们有一种新的编程语言。这门语言叫 Swift，它简直太棒了。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 183 期，录制于 2024 年 4 月 29 日。我是 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Bryce 一起采访 Doug Greger。这是五集系列采访的第四部分，在今天的采访中，我们聊了聊 Swift 编程语言。我花了一段时间——我不确定是不是很长，但在两个不同的场合，一次是在准备那次演讲时，另一次我想是在参加聚会时研究过它。我记得在那个演讲中，我对我研究过的语言进行了排名，包括 Rust、Swift、C++、D 和 Haskell。我想当时有三或
four different metrics I ranked them based on. And one of them was just like, I think it was like a happy face emoji. It was just based on like, it wasn't like anything concrete, like a happy face emoji it was just based on like it wasn't like anything concrete like a combination of ergonomics and how it makes you feel and swift won that like by a long shot and uh one of the things that i i love about swift especially coming from c++ is to a like remarkable extent i could just guess like what i thought the syntax would be after you kind of got a feel for the language. And 90% of the time, maybe even more, you'd just be right. And it starts as such a simple language. And I've heard Chris Lattner, either in podcasts or in talks that he's given, talk about this idea of like infinite hackability, that it starts off feeling like Python,
四种不同的指标来对它们进行排名。其中一个指标就像是一个笑脸表情符号。它不是基于任何具体的东西，就像一个笑脸表情符号，它只是基于人体工程学和它给你的感觉的结合，而 Swift 在这方面以绝对优势胜出。呃，关于 Swift，我特别喜欢的一点是，尤其是从 C++ 转过来的人，在很大程度上，当你对这门语言有了一定感觉后，我可以直接猜出它的语法是什么样的。而且 90% 的情况下，甚至更多，你都能猜对。它作为一门语言非常简单。我听 Chris Lattner 在播客或演讲中提到过“无限可黑客性”这个概念，即它一开始感觉就像 Python，
like a very simple, you don't need a main function, you don't need all the overhead. You know, Java is the classic example that gets picked on of the public static void main, blah, blah, blah, and you got to include everything. And I know that Java 21 or whatever version they're on now has drastically simplified that hello world example. But, you know. Don't apologize for Java. It took them until version 21 to simplify that.
非常简单，你不需要 main 函数，也不需要所有那些开销。你知道，Java 是最常被诟病的经典例子，什么 public static void main 之类的，你必须包含所有东西。我知道 Java 21 或他们现在用的任何版本已经极大地简化了那个 Hello World 示例。但是，你知道的。别为 Java 开脱了。他们花了 21 个版本才简化了那个例子。
We love, or at least I love all programming languages. There's something to be learned from every language, regardless of how you feel about it personally. But anyways, the point being is that Swift is, it's remarkable in just how well it's designed. And the only remark that I had after that was that I tried to go and then build like a mini game. And I was, I mean, I usually do most of my stuff on a Linux box.
我们热爱，或者至少我热爱所有的编程语言。无论你个人对它感觉如何，每门语言都有值得学习的地方。但无论如何，重点是 Swift 的设计非常出色。我当时唯一的评论是，我尝试去构建一个小游戏。我是说，我通常在 Linux 机器上做大部分工作。
Now, most of these days I do WSL2 using Ubuntu. And at the time, I think I tried to get some panel library for just sort of like, you know, JavaScript canvassing equivalent. And I, at the time, and so this was back i want to say like 2020 so this is now for four years ago roughly three and a half years ago i hit some walls pretty quickly and most of the and you know i'm not a i'm not a swifter i'm not sure what you call folks that program in swift a swifty i know that's already already taken. But most of the threads of the forums that I found basically recommended me buying, you know, an Apple machine, a laptop or something. They said, they gave you all the answers to what you wanted, but they said, if you really want a pleasant
现在，这些天我大部分时间都在使用带有 Ubuntu 的 WSL2。当时，我想找一个面板库，类似于 JavaScript 画布的东西。那是 2020 年左右，也就是四年前，大概三年前半，我很快就遇到了一些障碍。而且，你知道，我不是一个“Swifter”——我不确定你们怎么称呼用 Swift 编程的人，叫“Swifty”？我知道这个词已经被占用了。但我找到的大多数论坛帖子基本上都建议我买一台苹果机器，笔记本电脑之类的。他们给了我想要的答案，但他们说，如果你真的想要一种愉快的
experience, you should just go buy an Apple laptop, which obviously I wasn't about to go out and do. But I know that a long-term initiative has always been to kind of make the experience, the Swift experience on every platform just as good as the Mac experience. So I guess my main question after once again, a little mini monologue is what's the, you know, at currently Swift 5.10 and maybe Swift 6 in the future, what's the current state of like comparison of cross-platform development? You know, are we at parity with, you know, developing on a Mac machine or what's the story for someone trying to do it on Windows or someone trying to do it on a Linux machine? Yeah, I think I would say we are rapidly approaching parity. So we are not exactly there. We have a very long history
体验，你应该去买一台苹果笔记本电脑，这显然是我不打算做的。但我知道，一个长期的倡议一直是让 Swift 在每个平台上的体验都像在 Mac 上一样好。所以，在又一次小小的独白之后，我的主要问题是，在目前 Swift 5.10 以及未来可能的 Swift 6 中，跨平台开发的现状如何？你知道，我们是否达到了与在 Mac 机器上开发相当的水平？或者对于试图在 Windows 或 Linux 机器上进行开发的人来说，情况如何？是的，我想说我们正在迅速接近这种对等水平。所以我们还没有完全达到。我们在
on Apple platforms of servicing many millions of developers. So we've dealt with, you know, we've made a smooth experience there. But things have been moving very quickly to improve the experience everywhere else. And so if you looked in 2020, Linux support was there, but you could not have used it on Windows. There was no way, right? Linux support is much more advanced. A whole lot more of the package ecosystem works on Linux as well as Mac. Nowadays, there's editor support for VS Code and Emacs and NeoVim and so on through the SourceKill SP project. And Windows has come along really far, really fast in the last maybe year or two. This has been due to the efforts of the browser company.
苹果平台上有着服务数百万开发者的悠久历史。所以我们处理过，你知道，我们在那里创造了流畅的体验。但事情发展得非常快，以改善其他地方的体验。所以如果你在 2020 年看，Linux 支持是有的，但你无法在 Windows 上使用它。根本没法用，对吧？Linux 支持要先进得多。如今，更多的包生态系统在 Linux 和 Mac 上都能工作。现在，通过 SourceKit-LSP 项目，VS Code、Emacs 和 NeoVim 等编辑器都有了支持。而 Windows 在过去一两年里发展得非常快。这归功于 The Browser Company 的努力。
So this company makes a browser called Arc. Okay, I think I've heard of it on one of the podcasts. There's a bunch of Opera, Brave, and I think Arc is in that kind of not Chrome, Firefox, or Safari. Right, right. It's one of the other browsers. So the interesting thing about it is they're in Swift, and they actually have a number of compiler developers
这家公司制作了一款名为 Arc 的浏览器。好的，我想我在其中一个播客里听说过它。有很多 Opera、Brave，我想 Arc 属于那种非 Chrome、Firefox 或 Safari 的浏览器。对，对。它是其他浏览器之一。所以有趣的是，他们使用 Swift，而且他们实际上有许多编译器开发人员
that have been doing the hard work of making Swift work well on Windows. Interesting. And with their efforts and others from the Swift team, developers that have been doing the hard work of making Swift work well on Windows. And with their efforts and others from the Swift team, we've managed to bring up Windows, get it up to language parity, start getting more libraries working. There are nice installers for Windows now that help you get Swift up and running there. And they're betting their product strategy on the ability to use Swift to write all of their code in this browser and deploy it out to various platforms. So, yeah, I think the experience isn't exactly the same, for sure, but it is rapidly getting better. So many languages that get started by one shop or that that are
一直在努力让 Swift 在 Windows 上运行良好。有趣。在他们的努力以及 Swift 团队其他人的帮助下，我们成功地让 Windows 达到了语言对等，开始让更多的库工作。现在有很好的 Windows 安装程序可以帮助你在那里运行 Swift。他们将产品战略押注在能够使用 Swift 编写所有代码并将其部署到各种平台的能力上。所以，是的，我认为体验肯定不完全一样，但它正在迅速变好。很多语言由一家公司发起，或者
that are founded in one place and then become community projects and it takes a long time to truly become multi-platform you know community owned and driven things. Rust was started by Mozilla. I'm sure other examples don't come to mind, but I'm sure kind of- Google with Go, you know. There we go. Yeah. And, you know, I think the length of the period in which the perception is this is X org's language is internally at Apple, but it was a language that became the lingua franca on Apple's platforms, meaning that that heritage will be there for a long time. But I do imagine that as one of the key Swift people, that it does cause some difficulties in trying to grow the Swift audience, because there's probably a lot of people who have that assumption and bias that Swift is, is Apple's language and it's only for the iOS development. And I wonder what, um, what do you, and what does the Swift team,
在一个地方创立，然后成为社区项目，要真正成为多平台、社区拥有和驱动的项目需要很长时间。Rust 是由 Mozilla 发起的。我相信还有其他例子，但我一时想不起来，但我确定……Google 的 Go，你知道。没错。而且，你知道，我认为这种“这是 X 组织的语言”的认知持续的时间很长，因为它是苹果内部的语言，但它成为了苹果平台上的通用语言，这意味着这种传统将长期存在。但我确实想象，作为 Swift 的关键人物之一，这在试图扩大 Swift 受众时确实会造成一些困难，因为可能很多人都有这种假设和偏见，认为 Swift 是苹果的语言，只用于 iOS 开发。我想知道，你和 Swift 团队
the Swift community do to try to, um, uh, break past that, uh, that perception. Right. So I guess there's a couple things we do. The one is to acknowledge that perception head on. So I gave a talk back in November at a conference and I basically asked how many people here
Swift 社区在做什么来试图打破这种认知。好的，我想我们做了几件事。第一件事是直面这种认知。所以我在去年 11 月的一次会议上做了一个演讲，我基本上问了有多少人在这里
know what Swift is about. And there's a whole bunch of hands. That's fine. What it is. I said, okay, how many of you, keep your hands up, think it's Apple's language for writing iOS apps. And every, basically every hand stayed up like that. That is the perception, right? And I think you're right that it comes from its enormous success in that ecosystem. So over just a small number of years, maybe two years, two to three years out of the gate from when it was introduced, it took over the entirety of iOS app development, right? All the conferences, all the talks, the new things coming out were all Swift focused. And so I can
知道 Swift 是关于什么的。很多人举手了。这很好。它是什么。我说，好吧，你们有多少人，保持举手，认为它是苹果用于编写 iOS 应用程序的语言。基本上所有人的手都举着。这就是认知，对吧？我认为你是对的，这源于它在那个生态系统中的巨大成功。所以在它推出后的短短几年内，也许两到三年，它就接管了整个 iOS 应用程序开发，对吧？所有的会议、所有的演讲、出现的新事物都以 Swift 为中心。所以我可以
certainly understand. Why was that? Why was it so successful so quickly? So I think, obviously, because it's such a wonderful language uh sorry i mean it's true it's true i remember that there was a wwdc like announcement didn't the crowd like go go crazy or i don't know if you want to say crazy but like i remember watching a talk where it was announced like swift was announced and like the audience i don't know if it was a standing ovation but like the reception was like amazing. Like people were thrilled to hear that they were going to be getting, not to say anything bad about Objective-C, but they were basically going to be getting a modern, you know, functional
当然理解。为什么会这样？为什么它能如此迅速地成功？所以我认为，显然是因为它是一门如此美妙的语言……抱歉，我是说，这是真的，这是真的。我记得有一次 WWDC 的公告，观众不是都疯狂了吗？或者我不知道你是否想说疯狂，但我记得我看过一个演讲，Swift 被宣布了，观众……我不知道是不是起立鼓掌，但反响非常惊人。人们听到他们将要获得——并不是说 Objective-C 不好，但他们基本上将要获得一门现代的、你知道，函数式
flavored language of the 21st century to write their apps. And the demo I think that was given was pretty amazing. Like it was... Objective-C has served us so well for 20 years. We absolutely love it. But we had to ask ourselves the question, what would it be like if we had Objective C without the baggage of C? We did more than think about it. We have a new programming language. The language is called Swift and it totally rules. Swift is fast, it is modern, it is
风格的 21 世纪语言来编写他们的应用程序。而且我认为当时给出的演示非常棒。就像是……Objective-C 服务了我们 20 年，非常好。我们绝对热爱它。但我们不得不问自己一个问题，如果我们拥有没有 C 语言包袱的 Objective-C 会是什么样子？我们不仅仅是想想而已。我们有一种新的编程语言。这门语言叫 Swift，它简直太棒了。Swift 速度快，它是现代的，它是
designed for safety and it enables a level of interactivity and development that you've never seen on the platform. When it comes to speed, Swift is great. Compare Python, a popular scripting language, with Objective-C when it comes to something like, let's say, complex object sort. Objective-C is a lot faster, but Swift is faster still. And take something like RC4 encryption, extremely computationally intensive. Python gets utterly crushed in this particular benchmark.
为安全性而设计的，它实现了你在该平台上从未见过的交互性和开发水平。说到速度，Swift 很棒。将 Python 这种流行的脚本语言与 Objective-C 在某些方面进行比较，比如，假设是复杂的对象排序。Objective-C 快得多，但 Swift 更快。再看看 RC4 加密，计算密集型极高。Python 在这个特定的基准测试中被彻底碾压。
But look at Swift. Now, Swift is also modern with features like closures, generics, type inference, multiple return types, and namespaces. You know how many people at home are going, what in the heck are these guys talking about? Classic Apple, you know, they've rehearsed it. It's a very, very nice introduction to this new thing that you're getting. Yeah, I think there's some of that. I think, you know, I do think this is a very nice language. So, yeah, thank you.
但看看 Swift。现在，Swift 也很现代，具有闭包、泛型、类型推断、多返回值和命名空间等功能。你知道有多少人在家里会说，这些家伙在胡说什么？典型的苹果风格，你知道，他们排练过。这是对你即将获得的新事物的非常、非常好的介绍。是的，我想确实有这方面的因素。我想，你知道，我确实认为这是一门非常好的语言。所以，是的，谢谢。
But also, I think the community was ready for it. I also think we made it really, really easy to get into. This comes back to, I mentioned interoperability previously. So on day one of the Swift experience, we had file-by-file interoperability with Objective-C. So all of Apple's frameworks at the time were written in Objective-C, right? There's like hundreds of these things that come with the SDK. They were all Objective-C. You could use every single one of them very cleanly from within Swift. You could write, you could take your giant Objective-C project, this app you'd been shipping for,
但我也认为社区已经准备好了。我也认为我们让它变得非常、非常容易上手。这回到了我之前提到的互操作性。所以从 Swift 体验的第一天起，我们就有了与 Objective-C 的逐文件互操作性。所以当时苹果所有的框架都是用 Objective-C 编写的，对吧？SDK 自带了数百个这样的东西。它们全是 Objective-C。你可以从 Swift 内部非常干净地使用每一个。你可以编写，你可以把你巨大的 Objective-C 项目，这个你已经发布了
you know, years and write one single new source file in Swift and it would interoperate with your Objective-C cleanly. So there was no risk involved in trying it. And you don't actually see this with a whole lot of languages when they come out. Often you have to really buy in to a whole new stack, a whole new package ecosystem to actually use the language in something. We went this fine grained route so that many, many people were able to try it. The great thing about that is we got a ton of feedback. So we could iterate on the language, iterate on the tools, refine things to make it the language that people wanted it to be over the next couple of years.
多年的应用程序，用 Swift 编写一个单一的新源文件，它就能与你的 Objective-C 干净地互操作。所以尝试它没有任何风险。而且你实际上在很多语言刚出来时看不到这一点。通常你必须真正投入到一个全新的堆栈、一个全新的包生态系统中才能在某件事上使用这门语言。我们走了这条细粒度的路线，以便许多、许多人能够尝试它。这样做的好处是我们得到了大量的反馈。所以我们可以在语言上进行迭代，在工具上进行迭代，完善事物，使其成为人们在接下来的几年里希望它成为的语言。
And so I think the combination of it being better, it being a community that is used to change and used to adopting new technologies, and also the fact that there there was very little cost to trying it out meant that we were able to to move people pretty quickly and i mean i i guess uh probably i guess a part of it too is being in an ecosystem with a a centralized vendor that uh can can you know you didn't Swift didn't exist in a world where there were like 10 or 12 different organizations, all of whom needed to do that work to make all the frameworks interoperable. It was like, that could be like a top-down decision from Apple that, hey, we need
所以我认为，它更好、它是一个习惯于变化并习惯于采用新技术的社区，以及尝试它的成本非常低，这些因素结合在一起，意味着我们能够相当快地推动人们。而且，我猜……我猜其中一部分也是因为处于一个拥有集中化供应商的生态系统中，你知道，Swift 并不存在于一个有 10 或 12 个不同组织的世界里，所有这些组织都需要做这项工作来使所有框架可互操作。这就像是苹果的一个自上而下的决定，嘿，我们需要
to make this work. And there's one org that can sort of make the entire work across the entire platform. You try to do that in Linux, and you've got to talk to a whole bunch of different people, all of whom have different goals and objectives. And it's a lot harder, I think, to roll out the tools and the interop and the support that you need to. I think that's largely true. On the other hand, we're still in a big organization. So, right. And Swift, the interoperability that Swift enjoys
让它工作。只有一个组织可以某种程度上让整个工作在整个平台上完成。如果你试图在 Linux 上这样做，你必须与一大群不同的人交谈，他们每个人都有不同的目标和目的。我认为，要推出你需要的工具、互操作性和支持要困难得多。我认为这在很大程度上是正确的。另一方面，我们仍然在一个大组织中。所以，是的。而且 Swift，Swift 享有的与 Objective-C 的互操作性
with Objective-C is, or at least certainly initially, it was entirely based on the way that we designed and built the compiler. So it is a compiler feature that, so Swift, the compiler, embeds the entire Clang compiler in it. And the way we use a C or Objective-C or C++ library is we parse the headers. And the compiler has a mapping from feature X in C and C++ and Objective-C over to the way that Swift would represent that same thing. And then the code generator works along with Clang's code generator to make the API lineup. It sounds a lot like what the Carbon project is trying to get out of their interoperable story. I'm not sure how familiar you are with Carbon, but it's the... I'm only familiar with their goals and so on.
是，或者至少最初是，完全基于我们设计和构建编译器的方式。所以这是一个编译器功能，所以 Swift 编译器在其中嵌入了整个 Clang 编译器。我们使用 C 或 Objective-C 或 C++ 库的方式是解析头文件。编译器有一个从 C、C++ 和 Objective-C 中的功能 X 到 Swift 表示相同事物的方式的映射。然后代码生成器与 Clang 的代码生成器一起工作，使 API 对齐。这听起来很像 Carbon 项目试图从他们的互操作性故事中获得的东西。我不确定你对 Carbon 有多熟悉，但它是……我只熟悉他们的目标等等。
I know they've made interoperability with C++ a very first-class feature in their world and much of their strategy. I think they have mentioned Swift's approach because they certainly know about us. Yeah, but it's interesting because I think very few languages make this a priority or succeed in this way.
我知道他们已经使与 C++ 的互操作性成为他们世界中的一项非常一流的功能，也是他们战略的很大一部分。我想他们提到过 Swift 的方法，因为他们肯定知道我们。是的，但这很有趣，因为我认为很少有语言将此作为优先事项或以这种方式取得成功。
And we've talked in this podcast before about how hard it is for new languages to get off the ground. And I am a big believer in the power of inertia. I like to say Bryce's rule of computing is that inertia is king. And we've talked about this rule of thumb that a language has to be 10x better on some aspect to really break in. But that's, I think, less true if you've got a great interoperability story. And in fact, the interoperability can be the 10x improvement that, oh, wow, this is so easy for us to adopt and pick up and into migrates or something more modern. And we can do it incrementally. And that's how you get to the sort of rapid adoption that Swift's had. I'm not sure, Connor, if you have graphs or data to back this
我们之前在这个播客中讨论过新语言起步有多难。我非常相信惯性的力量。我喜欢说 Bryce 的计算规则是惯性为王。我们讨论过这个经验法则，即一门语言必须在某个方面好 10 倍才能真正突破。但我认为，如果你有一个很棒的互操作性故事，情况就不那么绝对了。事实上，互操作性可能就是那 10 倍的改进，哦，哇，这对我们来说太容易采用和上手了，可以迁移到更现代的东西上。我们可以逐步完成。这就是你获得 Swift 那种快速采用的方式。我不确定，Connor，你是否有图表或数据来支持这一点
up, but my understanding is that Swift is what, when Swift was, from when Swift was released to like the first couple of years, it had very rapid growth trajectory relative to other new languages or languages that reached the scales that it has. Obviously, if you look at languages that go from like zero to a thousand users, you know, that's not really a sample size that's sufficient to get the data. But if you're talking about going from zeros to millions of users, I don't think there's many languages that have done it as quickly as Swift has. I mean, I think that the language I would say is most similar in sort of rollout strategy is probably TypeScript, because it did very much the same thing of there was a JavaScript ecosystem, which is massive. It provided interoperability and a much better programming experience for that ecosystem and enjoyed very fast adoption. I was just going to say, there's a website, we'll leave a link.
，但我的理解是，Swift 是什么，当 Swift 从发布到最初的几年，相对于其他新语言或达到它这种规模的语言，它有非常快速的增长轨迹。显然，如果你看那些从零用户到一千用户的语言，你知道，那不是一个足以获得数据的样本量。但如果你谈论的是从零到数百万用户，我不认为有很多语言像 Swift 这样快。我的意思是，我认为在推广策略上最相似的语言可能是 TypeScript，因为它做了非常相似的事情，即有一个庞大的 JavaScript 生态系统。它为该生态系统提供了互操作性和更好的编程体验，并享受了非常快的采用。我正要说，有一个网站，我们会留下链接。
I think you can hyperlink exact sort of customizations of what you select. And it's called Languish and it's based on GitHub statistics. So, you know, it's all of these ranking things or take them with a huge grain of salt. But if you actually look at TypeScript versus Swift from the period of like 2012, which is when this site goes back to, to 2016, 17, TypeScript is, they've got similar curves at first, but then something happened in 2014 and then Swift just takes off. And according to these stats actually was higher ranked than TypeScript up until 2017. And then 2017, I think, you know, TypeScript is slowly taking over the JavaScript world. But yeah, like there's this period of two, two and a half years where Swift is, it's growing at this incredible rate, even faster than TypeScript at the time.
我想你可以超链接你选择的精确自定义设置。它叫 Languish，它是基于 GitHub 统计数据的。所以，你知道，所有这些排名东西都要持保留态度。但如果你真的看看 TypeScript 和 Swift 从 2012 年（该网站回溯到的时间）到 2016、17 年的对比，TypeScript 的曲线起初很相似，但 2014 年发生了一些事情，然后 Swift 就起飞了。根据这些统计数据，实际上在 2017 年之前，它的排名比 TypeScript 高。然后 2017 年，我想，你知道，TypeScript 正在慢慢接管 JavaScript 世界。但是的，有两到两年半的时间，Swift 的增长速度令人难以置信，甚至比当时的 TypeScript 还要快。
Yeah. So Swift was introduced in 2014. So. Well, I have no idea what the data prior to 2014 is. So, it says that in 2013 Q4, in 2013 Q3, it does have some numbers. So, I don't know what that's from. So, here's a possible theory. You said it's from GitHub data, right?
是的。所以 Swift 是在 2014 年推出的。所以。好吧，我不知道 2014 年之前的数据是什么。所以，它说在 2013 年第四季度，在 2013 年第三季度，它确实有一些数字。所以，我不知道那是什么。所以，这是一个可能的理论。你说它是来自 GitHub 数据，对吧？
Mm-hmm. Yeah. So, it's possible that the Swift projects, GitHub, Git history is now on GitHub and that it's looking at stuff from before it was publicly released. So that's probably. The Swift compiler projects, Git history goes all the way back to the dawn of time, which obviously predates when we launched it. So that that's probably where it comes from, but you would have a small number of users at that point. So one other thing that I think of when I think of Swift is I think of it as a teaching or an education language.
嗯嗯。是的。所以，Swift 项目的 GitHub Git 历史现在在 GitHub 上，它可能是在查看它公开发布之前的东西。所以这可能是。Swift 编译器项目的 Git 历史一直追溯到时间的黎明，这显然早于我们发布它的时间。所以这可能就是它的来源，但在那个时候你的用户数量会很少。所以当我想到 Swift 时，我想到的另一件事是它是一门教学或教育语言。
And even from the launch of Swift, there has been a big focus on education, not just of programmers, but of people who are learning to program for the first time. And not just of, like, career professional programmers who already, you know, know another language, but, you know, as a first language for people. Like, when I think of first language to recommend to people, Swift's often one that comes to mind.
即使从 Swift 发布之初，人们就非常关注教育，不仅是程序员的教育，还有第一次学习编程的人的教育。不仅是那些已经知道另一门语言的职业程序员，而是作为人们的第一门语言。就像，当我想到推荐给人们的第一门语言时，Swift 经常出现在我的脑海中。
Was that a focus from the start? You know, how did that come to be? So, I think it follows from one of our, know, how did that, how did that come to be? So I think it follows from one of our like philosophical points. So we believe very deeply in this notion of progressive disclosure, the idea that when you're starting out, things should be simple and straightforward. And as you grow, you start to need more capabilities. Those capabilities should be there and you can go learn about them, incorporate them. But there's two sort of buts. First of all, they shouldn't come to you way too early. So you shouldn't be forced to
那是从一开始就有的重点吗？你知道，那是怎么形成的？所以，我认为这遵循了我们的一点，你知道，那是怎么形成的？所以我想这遵循了我们哲学观点中的一点。我们非常深信“渐进式披露”这个概念，即当你开始时，事情应该是简单直接的。随着你的成长，你开始需要更多的功能。这些功能应该在那里，你可以去学习它们，并将它们整合进来。但有两个“但是”。首先，它们不应该太早出现在你面前。所以你不应该被迫
deal with a super advanced feature just because you step slightly outside of the bounds. And the other part is it shouldn't invalidate anything that you've learned so far. And so we do care a lot about the hello world experience, right? Like you print hello world and it works. And so that's it, like just print and then are in quotes. Hello world is fine. And we want it to be fairly simple to then grow into doing simple data structures and building, you know, your own types with structs and enums and so on. And we do like that it can be used as a learning language. I think it is valuable that people can learn a language and
处理一个超级高级的功能，仅仅因为你稍微超出了界限。另一个部分是它不应该使你到目前为止所学到的任何东西失效。所以我们确实非常关心 Hello World 的体验，对吧？就像你打印 Hello World，它就工作了。所以就是这样，只是 print 然后引号里的 Hello World 就行了。我们希望它变得相当简单，然后成长为做简单的数据结构，用结构体和枚举等构建你自己的类型。我们确实喜欢它可以用作学习语言。我认为人们可以学习一门语言并且
it can grow with them, right? So when they're ready, they can say, you know what? I want to learn about generic programming. You know, Swift has a generic system. say, you know what? I want to learn about generic programming. You know, Swift has a generic system. And, you know, the fun part about that is you can go and learn about generics and you write your identity functions and you learn how to write a protocol, which is basically Swift speak for a concept. And you write some generic algorithms. And then you realize that you've been using generics in your entire Swift existence. Because array is just a generic type defined in the library. And you've been writing like filter and map operations on arrays as part of, you know, just writing code.
它可以随他们一起成长是有价值的，对吧？所以当他们准备好时，他们可以说，你知道吗？我想学习泛型编程。你知道，Swift 有一个泛型系统。而且，你知道，关于那部分的有趣之处在于你可以去学习泛型，你编写你的标识函数，你学习如何编写协议，这基本上是 Swift 中对概念的说法。你编写一些泛型算法。然后你意识到你在整个 Swift 生存期间一直在使用泛型。因为数组只是库中定义的一个泛型类型。而且你一直在编写数组上的 filter 和 map 操作，作为你编写代码的一部分。
And those are simply generic algorithms that are expressed in the library on like the collection protocol. And so it was always there, right? Like this underlying more complex model was always there, butics. You have to have that down solid. Because there's nothing that kills progressive disclosure worse than something like a template and backtrace. That just throws you into all the complexity. But if you can keep it there but not required, you can have a language that is both you know complex to to model all the complicated scenarios that we need when we're doing like you know full full-on software engineering but still keep it simple and approachable enough well and there's also the the the fact that it um is so great uh for programming uh like GUIs and apps
而这些只是库中在集合协议上表达的泛型算法。所以它一直都在那里，对吧？就像这个潜在的更复杂的模型一直都在那里，但……你必须把它掌握扎实。因为没有什么比模板和回溯更能扼杀渐进式披露了。那只会把你扔进所有的复杂性中。但如果你能把它保持在那里但不强制要求，你就可以拥有一门既复杂到可以模拟我们在进行全面软件工程时需要的所有复杂场景，但又保持足够简单和易于接近的语言。嗯，还有这样一个事实，它对于编程……比如 GUI 和应用程序
and integrates so nicely with the Apple frameworks. I think makes it a really good teaching language, especially for like kids. And there's the, is it called Swift Playgrounds or something like that? What's the name of the thing, the app on? Right, yeah. So the Swift Playgrounds app lets you learn Swift
非常棒，并且与苹果框架集成得非常好。我认为这使它成为一门非常好的教学语言，特别是对于孩子。而且，它叫 Swift Playgrounds 还是类似的名字？那个应用程序的名字是什么？对，是的。所以 Swift Playgrounds 应用程序让你学习 Swift
on an iPad. So, you know, it's, it's a full Swift compiler, uh, under the hood, but there's, you know, guided tutorials to help learn aspects of the language in a fun and engaging way. And then you can go off and code whatever you want. And I, I, I've checked it out and it's like, I think it's like, like, especially for like, uh, somebody under 18, like, I think it's by far the best way to introduce programming to somebody. Like, I've tried to look at, you know, for family members, like, you know, how could, you know, a 13 or 14-year-old kid or even younger, like, learn, like, programming language. And, like, for the things that come to mind to me are, like, Python or Swift.
在 iPad 上。所以，你知道，它在底层是一个完整的 Swift 编译器，但有引导式教程来帮助以有趣和引人入胜的方式学习语言的各个方面。然后你可以去编写任何你想要的代码。而且我检查过它，我认为它就像，特别是对于 18 岁以下的人，我认为这是向某人介绍编程的最好方式。我试着研究过，你知道，对于家庭成员，比如，你知道，一个 13 或 14 岁的孩子甚至更小，怎么能学习编程语言。而且，我想到的东西是 Python 或 Swift。
And for Python, like, I can go, like, look for things. Like, yeah, there's, like, some things out there. There's, like python or swift and for python like i can go like look for things like yeah there's like some things out there there's like a bunch of different like courses but for like swift there's just this like this thing that's like like a a native like first class thing that's from the the people who make the language that you can just get on your ipad that's great um and it doesn't require a lot of setup like Like you can do it on an iPad, which is how like young people, you know, access the world these days. And it's just like it's so next level in terms of programming education. And I wonder whether there will be a long tail effect there of, you know, down the road, there will be a lot more people with proficiency in Swift because they will have learned it at a younger age because it's such a good experience.
对于 Python，我可以去寻找东西。比如，是的，有一些东西。有 Python 或 Swift，对于 Python，我可以去寻找东西。比如，是的，有一些东西。有很多不同的课程，但对于 Swift，就有这样一个东西，就像一个原生的、一流的东西，来自制作这门语言的人，你可以在你的 iPad 上直接获得，这太棒了。而且它不需要很多设置。就像你可以在 iPad 上做，这就是年轻人如今接触世界的方式。而且它在编程教育方面简直是下一个水平。我想知道那里是否会有长尾效应，你知道，在未来，会有更多的人精通 Swift，因为他们会在更年轻的时候学习它，因为它是一种如此好的体验。
It's possible. And I would expect that people also come through the, I want to build an app, what do I do realm where we have, this is an Apple technology, but SwiftUI is a declarative UI framework. It's an interesting case because if you look at SwiftUI, the UI is expressed in Swift code. It's quite elegant. It's very simple. You've got text fields and buttons and so on. And you don't even necessarily have to be a programmer to pick up enough to start working with it. I know designers have used it to be able to do essentially real code mock-ups. And it's one of those cases where I think we have succeeded at progressive disclosure because you can learn it as a first thing to do some UIs in this sort of fun and engaging way. Now, what's behind SwiftUI is a pretty amazing generic library. It uses all the features of the Swift generic system, but you're not confronted with it
这是可能的。而且我预计人们也会通过“我想构建一个应用程序，我该怎么做”的领域进来，我们有这个，这是苹果的技术，但 SwiftUI 是一个声明式 UI 框架。这是一个有趣的案例，因为如果你看 SwiftUI，UI 是用 Swift 代码表达的。它非常优雅。它非常简单。你有文本字段和按钮等等。你甚至不一定非得是一个程序员才能掌握足够多的东西来开始使用它。我知道设计师已经使用它来基本上做真正的代码模型。我认为这是我们成功实现渐进式披露的案例之一，因为你可以把它作为第一件事来学习，以这种有趣和引人入胜的方式做一些 UI。现在，SwiftUI 背后是一个非常了不起的泛型库。它使用了 Swift 泛型系统的所有功能，但你不会在 UI 层工作时面对它
when you're working at the UI layer. It's there if you need it. So yeah, it's been fun, right? We're trying to build a language for everyone. We hope that it can be your first language and we hope that it can grow with you as you do more sort of big and complicated things. I do feel like we've sort of done you a disservice in that we didn't ask you about Swift generics
。如果你需要它，它就在那里。所以是的，这很有趣，对吧？我们正在尝试为每个人构建一门语言。我们希望它可以成为你的第一门语言，我们也希望它可以在你做更多大型和复杂的事情时随你一起成长。我确实觉得我们有点对不起你，因为我们没有问你关于 Swift 泛型的问题
30 minutes ago. And I worry that we may not be able to do it justice in the second hour of our recording. Whoa, what do you mean second hour? Third hour of our recording. Sorry. Counting is Bryce's weakness in this podcast, clearly. I think maybe, I mean, do we want to dig into it now, Connor? Or should we maybe just plan to have Doug back for...
30 分钟前。而且我担心我们可能无法在录音的第二小时内公正地对待它。哇，你说的第二小时是什么意思？我们录音的第三小时。抱歉。计算显然是 Bryce 在这个播客中的弱点。我想也许，我的意思是，我们现在想深入研究它吗，Connor？还是我们应该计划让 Doug 回来……
We can definitely have you back, Doug. But I mean, I think we should definitely, I mean, we can't mention you. There's no way we can leave the listener. I mean, they've been, we did leave the listener wanting an explanation for this, at least for a couple episodes, because Lord knows how many episodes this is going to get cut into. The record is five, but this could potentially become six episodes. But I'm, my guess is that I'm going to cut these maybe a little bit longer so that we don't, I think our listeners are going to be upset if we take this whole podcast recording and then I dice it over a month and a half. I think they'll just – they'll end every 30-minute segment being like, what are we doing here? just been like itching to to record with connor about like these these various unrelated to this discussion algorithm uh inspirations and insights i've had recently so almost certainly there'll be more there'll be more episodes cut in between these but yeah let's give doug a chance to tell us a little bit about the swift genetics i think i think it'll be it'll be back to back to back doug doug doug doug doug for it'll either be over a month or over six weeks.
我们绝对可以让你回来，Doug。但我的意思是，我认为我们绝对应该，我的意思是，我们不能提到你。我们不可能让听众离开。我的意思是，他们一直……我们确实让听众想要一个解释，至少要等几集，因为天知道这会被剪成多少集。记录是五集，但这有可能变成六集。但我猜我会把这些剪得稍微长一点，这样我们就不会……我认为如果我们将整个播客录音拿出来，然后在一个半月内把它切碎，我们的听众会不高兴的。我想他们会……他们会结束每一个 30 分钟的片段，心想，我们在这里做什么？一直渴望与 Connor 录制关于这些与讨论无关的算法灵感和见解，所以我几乎肯定会有更多的剧集在这些之间剪辑，但让我们给 Doug 一个机会，告诉我们一点关于 Swift 泛型的信息。我想这会是连续的，Doug，Doug，Doug，Doug，Doug，它要么会持续一个月，要么会持续六周。
But definitely tell us a little bit about the generics in Swift. But also, you mentioned way back, it was probably an episode or two ago for the listener. You mentioned that, you know, half of its lifetime has been working up to Swift 6. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity.
但一定要告诉我们一点关于 Swift 泛型的信息。而且，你很久以前提到过，对于听众来说可能是前一两集。你提到过，你知道，它生命周期的一半时间都在为 Swift 6 做准备。请务必在你的播客应用程序或 ADSPthepodcast.com 上查看这些节目说明，获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。
That is the tagline of our podcast. That's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是我们播客的标语。那不是标语。我们的标语是带有信息碎片的混乱。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。